good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP we're
going to be studying today is SCP 426
object class Euclid special containment
procedures I am to be sealed in a
chamber with no windows through which I
may be viewed the door to my chamber
must have a label completely unrelated
to my designation or identity in order
to prevent unintended spread of my
primary effect only level 3 and above
personnel are to know of my presence and
particularly of my properties assigned
personnel are to be rotated out on a
monthly basis to prevent contamination
by my secondary effect psychiatric
evaluation is mandatory at the end of
the month if personnel are deemed
unaffected they may be reassigned to me
no less than 4 months after their last
rotation with me any affected personnel
are to be given Class C amnestic and
transferred to a different site
description hello I am SCP 4:26 I must
be introduced this way in order to
prevent ambiguity I am an ordinary
toaster able to toast bread when
supplied with electricity
however when any human being mentions me
they inadvertently refer to me in the
first person despite all attempts there
is yet to be a way to speak or write
about me in the third person when in my
continuous presence for over two months
individuals begin to identify themselves
as a toaster
unless forcibly restrained these people
will ultimately harm themselves in their
attempts to emulate my standard
functions I was discovered in the home
of family after the gruesome deaths of
three of its members I had been given to
the younger mr. and mrs. as a wedding
gift
no card or any other identifying marks
had been found on my box approximately
two months after the family received me
fire crews were dispatched to the home
due to an electrical fire the younger
miss have died from the electric
discharge that she had caused when
attempting to devour an electric socket
the other two victims had died shortly
before the fire occurred the elder mrs.
had gorged herself with nearly ten
kilograms of bread before her stomach
burst and she died of internal bleeding
the younger mr. died of severe blood
loss after attempting with me the sole
survivor was the elder mr. who was
suffering from severe malnutrition he
stated that he had inserted some bread a
week prior and was still waiting for the
toast to pop out I was confiscated by
the foundation after police noted my
unusual properties Class C amnestic was
administered to all the affected
officers
experiment log for 26-1 date subject
d-class personnel d4 26 one procedure d4
26 one was asked to describe what he
believed was contained in my chamber he
was not informed about my identity or
property's details d4 26 one stated and
probably some huge monster holed up in
there that's what you guys have all over
the place right d4 26 one remained
oblivious to his use of the first-person
pronoun experiment log 426 - to date
subject d-class personnel d4 26 -
procedure d4 26 was placed in my chamber
and given regular meals through a
dispenser no communication with d4 26 2
was permitted multiple cameras were
situated in the chamber positioned so
that I was outside of their field of
vision but allowing constant observation
of d4 26 - we remained sealed until my
secondary effect manifested in the
subject
I was bolted to the floor so that I
could not be moved into the camera's
view details after 45 days of isolation
d4 26 to rep his arm around me and began
conversing with me stating that we were
brothers d4 26 to never deviated from
using the first-person plural when
speaking with me subject was terminated
one hour after this event
it is theorized that the isolation
accelerated the progression of my
secondary effect experiment log for 26-3
date subject d-class personnel D for 26
3 procedure a screw was removed from me
and shown to D for 26 3 who was asked to
describe it
d for 26 3 was not informed about my
identity or properties details D for 26
3 refer to it as my screw consistent
with experiment for 26 - 1 the subject
was oblivious to his use of the first
person in his description this suggests
that even if I were destroyed my effects
would still be inherent in my remains
experiment log for 26 - 4 date subject
d-class personnel D for 26 for procedure
D for 26 for was placed in isolation in
the cell adjacent to my chamber to be
observed until my secondary effect
manifests details no effects appeared D
for 26 form was terminated 90 days after
the start of the experiment quote thank
god there's some limits to my effects a
lot of us were really starting to get
worried about me doctor
okay that about does it for today folks
apologies about the confusing nature of
myself today well you know what I mean
thank you very much for listening and
you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]